we've got some really promising news to
tell you about there's been a major
advance in the treatment of lung cancer
using drugs designed to trigger a
patient's immune system researchers
found that adding immunotherapy to
standard chemotherapy cuts the patient's
risk of dying or having the cancer
worsened within one year in half
compared with chemo treatment alone the
study was paid for by Merck a
pharmaceutical company that makes the
immunotherapy drug researchers looked at
our dr. David agus leads USC's Westside
cancer center he joins us from Los
Angeles with more on this David great to
see you so tell us about this new
research and what does it mean for
treating cancer going forward it's
pretty remarkable cancer cells were born
with the don't eat me signal on their
surface so the immune system doesn't
recognize it and this is a drug called
Pember ilysm AB great name rolls off
your tongue that actually blocks this
don't eat me signal allowing the immune
system to attack it you know for 120
years we've been doing clinical trials
trying to get the immune system to
attack cancer now for the first time
we're really seeing dramatic results
against cancer I gotta say David I like
hearing a great cancer doctors say that
this is remarkable so how does it work
well you know by blocking by an
activating the immune system allow it to
attack the cancer you're seeing patients
with lung cancer who normally when you
give chemotherapy they have 11 to 12
months of life expectancy and when you
add immunotherapy to it you're literally
seeing a doubling of how long they live
and so it still hasn't reached how long
they live so it's at least double so
very exciting and really groundbreaking
new way to treat most patients with lung
cancer a subtype called non-small cell
lung cancer which is the most dominant
subtype of lung cancer 160,000 people a
year die of this horrible disease and
now there's new hope is this a
breakthrough in a sense that will lead
to perhaps other discoveries does this
open a new pathway or is this just a
great new development in immunotherapy
use well you know classically in cancer
we start drugs in the end stage of
disease you know where people are
failing failed everything and then we
see if it helps
immunotherapy had some benefit there and
this is moving it upfront so it's going
to benefit large numbers of patients
and what we're seeing now is it is
betting multiple we call it body types
so other kinds of cancer bladder cancer
melanoma kidney cancer we're seeing
benefit and we're seeing more there are
literally hundreds of clinical trials
ongoing now across the country seeing
how can we use it in other types of
cancer but this is hope on the frontier
it's not a cure but it is offering a
long-term and well tolerated therapy
that can actually lengthen people's
lives who you talk about lengthening
people's lives without getting too ahead
of ourselves could we possibly be
looking at cures in the near future
you know the c-word curing cancer is
something we shy away from and so my
goal is to make people live a long and
quality life while not having a lot of
side effects from the treatment and
that's where we're going now so cure is
something that we certainly dream of but
I don't think we're there yet but
lengthening life in a quality way we're
seeing that with this drug all right
promising the new discoveries thank you
dr. agus